I'm shocked this is a really long  relationship yeah I I just thought maybe  like you trade in these dudes like are  you in love oh you are oh yeah look at  you you're gonna marry this guy  maybe Wow Oh smile look at you I love  him  Wow you were really hot on him the  second date I saw you guys I think I  fell in love with him when I first saw  him  like at first sight I think so I just  wasn't his setup or something what was  it again we met on the internet we met  on I've read that it was a dating app  that is for creative people or something  what dating app is for creative people I  don't want to say the name of it unless  I am an investor that are you serious  yeah why he all right it's called Jews  who love big dongs